[Music]
hmm appreciate you looking out for a
young gun yes sir yes sir I got your
water if you need to I guess
not quite on the level you've been at
but uh we're out here trying you know I
appreciate taking the time we're
chilling here at Uptown post game where
you pack it out every time we work
together you sold out like every show
and this all these were packed out like
what it what is your connection to
Atlanta man well you know it's not a
really a connection I just have been
coming here so long it just feels like
family and it's like pretty much the
gospel I just come to really keep it 100
with the people and to go around the
country for like a year cuz I only come
around for like twice a year and when I
get here III teach what I've learned
just to put people for game motivator
and if I could just reach one person out
of the whole weekend to change their
life that's important to me what was
your first time performing in even do
coming over 30 years yes first time
performing Atlanta I came here in 1988
with a group called NWA oh okay yeah so
that was my first time coming here had
an incredible time I guess that was
before you got banned from the tour no I
was I was like yeah it was before I got
banned yeah we had just started but the
only band me in four cities and they let
me back on the tour oh oh yeah only four
cities it was it was really the Midwest
they just too raw for them yeah they
thought I was I was trying to sign a
riot we were saying yeah because it was
a movie at that time that came out
called Mississippi Burning
uh-huh and I talked about it on stage
and bone that was the rest is history
where did you actually start what was
the actual I started up in Los Angeles
California at the comedy act I'm not the
kind comedy act theater the Comedy Store
you know and I'm like how you guys have
the comedy clubs now bring that back in
a day yeah Robin Harris so you know I go
way back to the Robin Harris days the
comedy act theatre that was like I mean
that was everybody right wasn't like
Eddie Murphy yeah everybody came through
there Robin Harrison bear
the Wayans family Keenan
the whole the whole shebang well my
rocks well we didn't know what it was
gonna become so you didn't know what it
was like it was just it happened you
know what I mean
yeah wow we didn't know all this was
gonna happen for all of us and what
wasn't that created because like a lot
of black comics weren't getting put up
in the other clubs so they kind of our
own lane right that's exactly what it
was so why do you think comedy is so
segregated like that because it still is
it's just the way life is you know just
like you have Bentleys and Cadillacs and
Porsches everybody got they only know
what they like and it's the same thing
with comedy it's um you could pick who
you like who you don't like and rock it
from there
what's your experience in white rooms
I'll do the same thing I use a little
bit more personality but I have the same
effect they still love me which is good
a lot of people don't know whatever yeah
I have an incredible credible white
following it's like unbelievable
but I had to earn it took years from the
ketchup cuz I was ahead of my time I was
way ahead of my time yeah everything's
real man that's what's crazy about your
show and like I've got to ask for all
the fans like this who raised you
what where did that came from a lot of
different things and women I've dated I
couldn't understand some of the things
females was doing and I would look at on
my cuvee see because it really didn't
make any sense and when you see that it
was just fascinating so I just started
saying it before I was saying it to
myself before I actually sitting on
stage and I think it took me like two
years to actually say it on stage what
wasn't something like that I was going
to use and then one day boom it just
happened well definitely developing
jokes is something that takes a long
time and getting good at comedy takes a
long time and what is amazing about your
command of the room is insane like you
can you can take them up but you can
take them down and just be manipulating
them the whole time right like and they
still pay attention they pay attention
to everything everything and they lean
in right and I've seen you work multiple
times now and that is
consistent yes like that is part of like
your flavor really right like your style
but like as people know in comedy
developing that style in that confidence
takes years of stage time some people
have it I just you know no disrespect
another egotistic I just think I had it
from day one but I think it comes from
other things I was a track star I used
to model when I was young I think all
those things help to build confidence
what kind of model way I use the model
clothes you claim fashion shows all that
kind of stuff so you've always been a
performer yes ever since I was young
yeah yes is that is that why you went to
a performance arts high school no I
didn't go to performances High School I
just went to this night of high school
and then I went to college and then from
I went to this thing called The
Groundlings everybody the Jim Belushi's
and all I'm doing I was there for a
while and they actually said that um
that I have phenomenal talent so the
rest is history
you did like sketches and stuff at
growlings improv yeah I did look at
those sketches yeah I'd like that
I like the stuff okay I looked up your
high school and it said it was
performance arts but I mean that's after
you left okay
you also have a masters and yes yes I
got that Cal State Northridge in
California so this is all I mean it
comes off like you're like do this dude
and I mean you do have a background that
is you know whether you got a record
you got a rap sheet and all this but
like there's you know there's some
technique going on behind it's not just
all like coming out like this is all
well developed yes yes I could tell that
is mastermind yeah what's amazing about
your your career as well as like you
have had these quote hiccups maybe you
know in people and can hear other
interviews with you talking about
stealin Charlie Murphy's watch my stuff
with like PD and Suge Knight and all
that but like why do you think you've
been able to sustain a career even with
these kind of like
roadblocks one that to do with the
Puffy's and the [ __ ] it really didn't
have nothing on the career it's just
because I think all of us entertainment
they think that it did have something to
do with it like they the type of people
that will block you or ban yourself
right never happened it was never even
like that and some of these things
happen over 30 years
goes I find it fascinating that people
still remember but the reason why people
so talk about it because my stand-up has
always been so good and when you good
and when you're really good people have
to have something to attach with your
journey so since they have that attached
to my journey
that's what spoked about the most so I'm
really excited that I was able to go on
The Breakfast Club early this year and
really put it out there cuz it was set
off around the world so it was cool
you gotta get paid no no we good we
can't go I'm sorry man
yeah so other stuff you talked about on
there is just you not only comedy but
like you've really been doing comedy
over 30 years and you've really broken
down a couple barriers for people I mean
you opened up for a lot of musicians
that was one thing because before even
Dolf was a great stand-up I still wasn't
doing all the comedy rooms because one I
didn't have a JIT I'm pretty much my own
person you know cuz I always had a
philosophy that I didn't want to ever
call somebody to ask them what did I
have work or to be blowing them up to
know when I'm gonna when I'm gonna eat
next mmm so I have to know when I'm
gonna eat when I'm gonna get my money I
have to be in control of that I can't
sit around away for somebody to book me
how many weeks are you on the road man
I'm gonna work every week every weekend
every year gets better and better you
know like it's coming up now that imma
be in a different city almost every day
and knocked over Wow yeah hit the city
go to sleep and get up the next day and
fly to another city it's gonna be it's
gonna be abusing
long as I get my breasts I'm cool and
all these shows are being booked by you
you don't have to myself no I don't have
a agent I do it myself so what what is
your kind of what what is kind of your
like give a stage technique where's your
technique on getting booked and stuff do
you reach out to these people or like
they were a little bit everything I'll
reach out people reach out to me and
then we negotiate and I tell them what I
wanted and what I don't want and the
rest is history
yeah everybody can't do that so that's
that's what's amazing about it man it's
like your your business sense yes is
amazing and that's something I I need to
work on heavily is like my business
sense right it's like I've I've been
focusing on okay stage stage let's get
good let's get good yeah and now it's
like especially even when it just comes
to talking money right you just got to
know what you're worth
uh-huh you got to have that attitude and
you got to be flexible with negotiation
so you hit somebody with a number first
you acts on how big is the room okay
then you got to know if you really can
pull that many people then is based on
you to open and act the middle I go to
headliner and every physician has a fee
so if you know opening act it's a circle
price if you a middle act as a surprise
you've your headline that your headliner
you want to know how many chairs is in
the room and you do the math and then I
always try to be fair with the promoter
so if it's a thousand see the 2,000 see
there you do what the math is you tell
them what you want but what happens over
the last 15 years a lot of youngsters
will tell for motor all in that means
they'll give you a certain fee and you
take you get your own hotel and you get
your own hey I don't do that okay you
got to pay for my air and my hotel plus
my salary okay you know because I I'm
good I'm worth it and that's just the
way it's going down so what does that
math on like a thousand seater like what
do you mean like you taking account the
food and drink the the cover just just
the theater you find out how much you do
to man you know you get your calculator
you ask how much the door price is gonna
be okay you do the math when you see
what's there and you know instantly what
you should get out of that it was
eighteen twenty thousand you know maybe
you want five thousand that plus in
hotel I just got to know it you know mhm
just got to know it and I always tell
people all money's good money sometimes
I'll do a show for a thousand dollars
you know depending on where is that long
as they take care hotel but yeah I could
do a lot with a thousand dollars so I'm
not afraid of money you know I go get it
was a thousand twenty thousand I go get
it you mentioned young people not being
able to negotiate very well and like
just going all in on just
not getting their air and like room and
board all taken care of
what are some other mistakes you think
younger cats are making in the game I
think I would say that's pretty much it
uh-huh you know you Pomona should never
tell you all in it should be this is
gonna be my salary and you still pay for
my air and hotel it's no other way
around it how do you feel about the new
wave of more guests like online comics
and things like that
do you I think it's fascinating to get a
following like that but some of these
people get the following but they don't
have the talent to deliver on stage
because that's why they call it show
business some people never saw the
sizzle and the state some people just
saw the sizzle but they don't have the
steak uh-huh you know you got a vote so
you use supportive of it you think it's
a good for coming here I don't know if
it's good you just gotta really follow
the wave you know whatever you thought
entertainment was 30 years ago throw
that out the window because it still
applies to certain things but has really
changed from snapchat Instagram you know
people get all these followers and they
think if they got a million followers
that really they are really a celebrity
but that doesn't really I don't
calculate to your fans coming out you
know so it does it well you've seen the
game of all over decades I mean how how
has it changed would you say since you
started what was just really the
Instagram thing and and and people doing
a lot more skits and videos and some
people do videos and skits but think
because they did that that makes them
famous because their video went viral
mm-hmm your video just went viral
it doesn't mean a million people are
coming to your show doesn't mean even
5,000 people come to you so now that's
what I mean it doesn't get for some
people who use that as a negotiating sky
can't hate on it right fall for it but
doesn't just make any sense how the
audience has changed over the years
it's still the same I think funny is
funny mm-hmm you know you finding you
funny and that's it you know I've been
around a long time so the people who are
laughing at my stuff now I probably used
to have sex with the mothers back in the
day now they keep kids out here
[ __ ] them too you know that's funny
what's amazing about your grind is like
you are a straight-up hustler like a
hustler you you are a believer in like
multiple streams and all this right like
what what other kind of besides comedy
like what other kind of hustles have you
been apart yeah you know my albums
alright interviews on albums from AMG to
Timbaland - oh my god
Lloyd CD you know I do this on a lot of
albums like Jazze PHA mm-hm all that
stuff I do
I just try to do it what is it what our
interlude is like when you song is
playing in then the next song coming in
today at the comedy skit in between then
you go to the next song yeah I do that
too oh man yeah I got a podcast
oh what's that what's that called punk
ass just TK Kirkland okay yeah okay but
that's what you're doing now but like
past ones mean you actually use the own
clubs right at one time well never
really own it I just you know owned a
couple liquor bottles you know the vodka
and all that kind of stuff and gasoline
companies and I try to keep some things
low-key you know cement is that another
little oil dividend Da'Ville and that
type of stuff you know I just have just
have met some phenomenal people my
lifetime you just said Dibble and dabble
in oil like that's like a common thing
like that yes I do stuff I do stuff in
Amsterdam and all that kind of stuff and
you know Rotterdam
Africa Dubai gosh yeah
how do you even get involved in that
just told me at the right place at the
right time yeah different people just
knowing how to talk to people
yeah just pretty much know how to talk
to people using that master's degree in
yes communication where any uh I guess
learning these did you learn that all
these moves from the streets though is
that how you were able to learn how to
talk to people and stuff I think is that
and
[Music]
just using common sense mm-hmm just yeah
it's pretty much common sense and be
mature and know who you are online
because I saw you saying one interview
like in the 80s and 90s you were like
the plug for everything and I was
o'clock everything so what exactly does
that mean everything like if you was
traveling out the hustler oh yeah my
ticket sir could you excuse us one
second that bothers my back yeah yeah I
can't do all that that's scary I can't
do this
t-to the money yeah that's my man yeah
you know people standing by that's some
dirty [ __ ] to be you know the street
chain don't like people standing behind
you and everything I can't have it what
was it what was it like growing up you
grew up in Jersey City what was that
life like you know I was pretty much
quiet track star my mom business stay
focused and just ran for life every day
and it got me out the hood and it took
me you know that was the start that was
the beginning of the journey what about
the family with my mother and family
yeah just your family like growing up
what would yeah my family was
interesting you know my mom was cool my
dad was interesting my you know regular
family regular fans just regular family
Cade comes from a regular family that's
just one thing I haven't really heard
you talk about much yeah I'm talking
about my family too much what is what is
the reason behind that um pretty much
because I was in college most of my life
and they were still back home I was I
left it at 18 years old so I we were
still close but I just never went back
oh you just just yeah it made it out I
made it out so I would go visit but it
wasn't like we were cousin those those
years are really important to ya to
learn stuff but that's the empty void in
my life mm-hmm I mean I researched you a
lot and I was like he doesn't talk about
his family yeah I was like I wonder what
what happened I love them but yeah but
my family's deceased you know my mother
my father and both my brothers all gone
so everybody's here everybody's gone oh
man so it's just me but it's you know
it's cause life yeah
yeah and you made it out you know you've
you're survivor
yes which is amazing mm-hmm
I appreciate your time for doing this
package oh now you're ready to the end
yeah because I got to catch a plane
early in the morning absolutely I'm
extremely tired and I respect my body so
I really have to make sure I get go to
bed and get some rest
well I respect your time as well sir now
the one question asked every comedian on
here yes is a story of getting booed or
a complete travesty bombing on stage
because we all go through it
no we go we all show you've never had
never been booed never been booed never
been moved what's the what you got a
story of just it all going wrong just a
bomb you've had two bombed I bombed one
time but it was a middle of my I was
really doing well and what happened it
was this show was set up wrong it was in
Arizona okay and the promoter had
dancers and stuff on the show it
destroyed the momentum okay because this
dance thing was not fit for a comedy
show mm-hmm so before because they had
it set up certain way it put me in a
dangerous position that's the reason why
I would say I never really Bob but for a
straight stand-up comedy show up now I
never happened I've always been blessed
so people just didn't laugh did like
people leave actually boots oh you did
get me I actually got booboo because it
was set up that right so the reason why
I'm talk about that cuz it wasn't a real
comic show where was Ryan walking
meeting after another can me at another
comedian know so that was a long time
ago Wow well I appreciate you taking
this time out Joe it's good to see you
doing what you're doing yeah because
that's what comedies about comedy is to
get put on and find other lanes to make
money because it may not be that you get
funny in comedy mm-hm he may be that you
blow up as a radio host and maybe that
you blow up as a writer right giving
example David Letterman was a stand-up
comedian but the comedy led to him being
a TV host but he never did stand-up
anymore
is the host but he still had a quick wit
so that's what comedians have to
understand you mean that you might be a
convenient but it comedy might take you
somewhere else to make a better life
yeah well I mean you've dropped so much
wisdom before we get out of here is
there anything else you want the world
to know
no I just want everybody lived a life to
the fullest and stay focused and know
that whatever you're going through if
it's not murder or rape or being a
pedophile that you can get out of it and
persevere and move forward you know and
made your pain free champagne if you
just say your full name into the
microphone - yes my name is TK Kirkland
aka t2 the [ __ ] K may God bless
you
peace TK Kirkland thanks for being on
hot breath yes sir
[Music]
I breath